como se sintió
así me siento yo todos los días
pero no sé de qué habla la persona yo ya
estoy acostumbrado y estoy bien
pero cuando yo era niño
era un poco difícil para mí
porque yo no entendía ocupen día de lo
que hablaban las personas en un grupo
pero no entendía absolutamente nada y no
aprendía bien de lo que yo viví
por eso
no quiero que termine el espacio lo que
yo viví
pero aquí en méxico cada año nacen cinco
mil niños sordos
el 5 por ciento de los sordos son papas
por donde hoy ente el 95% los niños
sordos de papá son oyentes
que pueden comunicar puedan expresar
pero el 95% de los niños que son papás
oyentes
este niño sordo que van a una escuela
particular doliente
donde no hay lengua de señas mexicana
los niños no aprenden profundamente lo
que los sentimientos que podamos
expresar
pero cuando yo aprendí a los 18 años la
lengua de señas mexicana mi vida cambió
mucho
porque a esa edad yo aprendí una lengua
de señas mexicana y de pueden entender
el significado de la palabra
puede leer puede aprender a escribir
mejor
este lo que quiero que todos los niños
sordos puedan expresar sus sentimientos
puedan expresar sus opiniones
pero yo cuando yo era niño
mi vida ha sido difícil
yo soy el único niño sordo de la escuela
porque todos hablaban y escuchaban y
muchos niños podían platicar mover los
labios y yo batallaba por que no
entendía cuando los niños platicaban
y siempre me escondía
de atrás del salón de clase por el
estacionamiento honesta al oscar
yo me escondía
a ver siendo un niño que quería jugar
conmigo pero me apena también que no
quería participar o jugar con el niño
porque no extendida de lo que hablaban
los dedos que platicaba
lo más difícil porque los solos y los
niños que se reían y yo pensaba que se
estaba burlando de mí y yo me enojaba
pero no no era eso no no comprendía y
hablaban de otro chiste u otra cosa
pero lo que me fortaleció y lo que me
hizo ser fuerte
en mi papá me han llevado me han metido
un mundo de inclusión y esto a mí me ha
hecho ser más fuerte de mí mismo mi mamá
me llevaba todos los días a la escuela a
la terapia para ello desempeñar muy bien
a la socia y en el campus en tu atención
múltiples me la pasaba o copiando tarea
me la pasaba esté leyendo las libretas y
eso no tenía un aprendizaje profundo
significativo pero en el camp en el
centro de atención múltiple aprendí a
leer los labios aprendí un poquito a
expresar la palabra pero no me enseñaban
exactamente el significado profundo de
la palabra se lo agradezco mucho de todo
corazón a mi mamá ya mi papá siempre me
llevaban a la escuela para que yo
pudiera aprender mucho mejor
pero plástica una pequeña historia
en la escuela primaria yo quería
divertirme
yo veía que había un pizarrón que había
esta suela y en un momento saque una
tachuela y me la pasaba picando a la
niña porque quería hacer una travesura
y yo porque yo quería divertirme pero no
pensaba que se iban han molestado se
iban a enojar
y después puse una tachuela en una de
las sillas para cuando una niña una
maestra 60 by sapphire y se ha afectado
y por qué pasó después la maestra hizo
un reporte a mi papá para llamar la
atención entonces cuando llegué a mi
casa mi mamá me estaba regalando
haciendo en mi mitad
yo no entendía muy bien de qué así que
pues ignoraba cuando era muy travieso
pero cuando llegó mi papá de trabajo
en 69 mímica
y me hizo un ejemplo de que tú esto no
está bien
y él solo me hace usted
y aprendí gracias a mi papá a entender
que eso no está bien y ya no voy a serlo
jamás
pero también me acuerdo no me acuerdo
muy bien de kinder
pero en la primaria la secundaria ese
tipo de aprendizaje que vivir o
aprendido a comportarte la sociedad
y en la secundaria de la prepa pues ha
sido muy fácil para mí porque me ha
pasado copiando las tareas en una prepa
abierta y me ha pasado copiando las
reacciones en internet del libro pero no
lo aprendía profundamente y significado
pero una vez que cambió mi vida cuando
me incorporé a la universidad
tecnológica santa caterina es una
universidad inclusiva para fort no era
la única universidad incluyente
y para todas las personas con
discapacidad haya internet
un día mi papá me llevó a la iglesia
para ver opciones de carrera y plan de
estudios con la inclusión
y demostrado en el plan de estudios que
había mencionados en la en la mesa mi
papá y yo empezamos a abrir las las
opciones de carrera había una carrera
que me gustó pero no recuerdo muy bien
de qué era así que yo cogí ésta
y la coordinadora me dijo la perdone
esta carrera no hay intérprete
entonces yo le dije para que me pregunta
entonces la magnitud de la inclusión
escogida carrera de diseño de tecnología
de información y conocí a un compañero
que me cambió toda la vida porque
aprendí la lengua de señas mexicano
y puede integrar y adaptarme rápidamente
con mis amigos en los 6 meses con los
sistema stroke voy a preguntar qué
significaba esto que significaba más
palabras con significados profundos
mi amigo kevin lópez el viene desde
honduras y vino aquí a méxico a estudiar
a la misma universidad
tecnología sap catering es un gran amigo
mío
y yo vi que
sabe muchísimo a se han integrado muy
bien a 6 y he visto que su vida ha
mejorado mucho todo lo que él aprendió
desde muy pequeño la lengua de señas
mexicana con su familia con sus amigos
su maestros desde muy pequeño y ahí yo
me di cuenta que porque él sí logró
desenvolver ser más rápido que yo
después de que me gradué de la
universidad como ingeniero en el sistema
de información
de grado también me metí como
practicante a una empresa profesional
y conocí a una compañera que se llama
rocío garcía gutiérrez
ella me invitó a un proyecto tan
interesante pero ella tampoco y no
sabían nada de lengua de señas
y nos juntamos para hacer un proyecto de
trabajo adicional a lo que tenemos en la
empresa
ella aprendió mucho de mi tío mi
historia vio la cultura de los forros
dio que todos los niños batallar mucho
para aprender así que ella reinició su
trabajo y se dedicó a estudiar un
diplomado en especialización en la
educación especial y nosotros empezamos
a querer trabajar un proyecto para
ayudar a los niños sordos y creamos una
aplicación que se llama activa escena
que es una aplicación para que todos los
niños y todas las ciudades puedan
aprender la lengua de señas es un juego
interactivo gratuito
que nunca pensé que esta aplicación iba
a tener muchísimo impacto
porque al desarrollar estas aplicaciones
hemos impactado y hemos generado 350 mil
descargas
bueno
hecho esos cuatro años que hemos
trabajado en de leucemia nos hemos dado
cuenta que el impacto real hacia los
maestros y los niños sordos llegaban una
conexión muy fuerte por una herramienta
de comunicación que es la lengua de
señas mexicana usando esa plataforma de
aprendizaje ya llega aún mucho a la
comunidad es muy lejana en oaxaca
chiapas y eso algo muchísimo a los niños
a incorporarse muchísimo y una vez
participamos en un programa de charlas
que le van que levantamos este proyecto
esa iniciativa para demostrar lo que
podamos hacer e impactar a la comunidad
del sordo
en este proyecto
que estamos muy nervioso en esa
situación porque no sabíamos que íbamos
a hacer no sabíamos que nos íbamos a
lanzar y yo le dije a rocío tranquila
este proyecto es para ayudar a los niños
sordos y así fue como logramos le juzga
a este proyecto
hemos hecho muchos diferentes vídeos
mucha plataforma visual es todo gratuito
para que los niños puedan aprender
una vez uno de los proyectos que hemos
participado fue cuando fuimos a españa a
la fundación once para demostrar lo
valioso que tienen estas herramientas en
muchos niños han aprendido a comunicarse
de todo tipo de discapacidad con
síndrome de down con autismo
hemos trabajado en en crear que esto
permita que los niños puedan expresar
sus sentimientos puedan expresar la
palabra el amor por su papá es lo que a
mí me motiva a seguir trabajando en esta
aplicación para no que nos haya una
barrera entre su papá
ahora en lo que actualmente yo trabajo
son pruebas y plataformas en una
compañía que se llama softtek y nos
enfocamos mucho en proyecto de
responsabilidad social y en proyecto
para romper las barreras de comunicación
para que estos niños no vivan lo que yo
viví antes y quiero que estos niños
crezcan y desempeñen mucho mejor porque
la comunicación es una herramienta tan
importante que nos permite conectarnos e
integrar a las demás personas
los puede escuchar y hablar escuchar con
mis ojos y hablar con mis manos
ahora quiero que me vea como acabo de
hacer la cena y les quiero enseñar un
poquito quiero que usted aprendan algo
de cena yo los invito
hazlo esto significa gracias hablo
ahora usted ha gando a ver
ahora esta señal nos vemos pronto
hágalo usted
ahora otra vez muchas gracias nos vemos
pronto
/ significa mucha gracia nos vemos
pronto háganlo ustedes a ver
muchas gracias